I'm Kennedy I'm Bill hemmer I'm Harris
Faulkner and this is the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
July 27 2022
I'm Dave Anthony
another interest rate hike is expected
today as the Federal Reserve faces a
tricky time with the economy they got to
thread the needle they got to raise
rates high enough fast enough to slow
growth keep inflation expectations down
but not so high so far that it
undermines things like housing and
pushes in a recession I'm Jessica
Rosenthal a deadly drug is pouring into
the country thousands of Americans are
dying and lawmakers are arguing over the
solution as some in law enforcement say
a sense of urgency is missing so it's
really sad and it's very very negligent
on behalf of the government that they're
not stepping up and they're not doing
the job to protect the Citizens First of
America and I'm Stephen Moore I've got
the final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
how healthy or sick is the economy we'll
find out over the next two days
inflation is much too high and we
understand the hardship it is causing
Federal Reserve chairman Jerome Powell
said that back in May after a second
interest rate hike this year we'll hear
from him again today after increase
number four with the FED trying to Tamp
down inflation in the 9.1 percent
consumer price increase in June when gas
at a record high but could those rate
hikes slow the economy too much My Hope
Is We Go From This rapid growth to
steady growth and uh so she will see
some coming down but I don't think we're
going to uh God willing I don't think
we're going to see recession President
Biden and his economic team say even if
a report tomorrow on GDP shows a second
straight quarter of economic contraction
we won't be in a recession
Republican senator Rick Scott says what
I think if you go to Google and you put
in recession and you look at the
definition I think it's two quarters of
negative GDP the White House is actually
a recession is declared by a group
called The National Bureau of economic
research assessing many factors but
Senator Scott counters when we had
negative GDP what's that mean that means
you make less money that means people
are going to get laid off that means the
value of things are going to go down
like your home so the FED has its work
cut out for dealing with all this job
creation is good unemployment is low
people have work but obviously inflation
is very very high painfully High Mark
zandi is Chief Economist for Moody's
Analytics that is really cutting into
people's purchasing power and so we're
struggling and obviously the FED has to
get that inflation down so they're
raising interest rates growth is going
to slow so this is a very tricky or a
very tricky period here very close to uh
to going into recession yeah so you say
say tricky the FED for quite a while had
kept interest rate levels really really
low then the economy did better after
covid
last year there was all the talk that
inflation was only going to be temporary
not really a big deal the FED did not
take action do you think that was a
mistake
uh yeah in hindsight for sure but I
think what the mistake here was or what
was not understood was the pandemic the
pandemic you know if you think back a
year ago Dave when the vaccines got
rolled out we thought it was over uh
remember President Biden giving a speech
but go out and enjoy your families on
July 4th but of course he declared
independence we declared independence
from covid that day last year yeah now
you know and obviously that wasn't the
case and so then we had Supply
disruptions and labor market issues and
that just caused inflation to go higher
and then of course Russia's invasion of
Ukraine that wasn't even on the radar
screen that came on you know late last
year early this caused oil prices go
Skyward and that's added to the
inflationary pressure so yeah it was a
mistake but you know I think an
understandable one given the
uncertainties around the pandemic and of
course the surprise of the Russian
invasion
certainly gas prices were a huge Factor
we had a record high in June
how big a factor is energy for inflation
and the ripple effect from energy to
other areas of spending in the economy
yeah it's a big deal uh just to give you
a sense of it so inflation let's say is
nine percent we're rounding more than
half of the increase in inflation over
the past years is related to those
higher oil prices and of course that's
because of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
now Republicans have maintained that
look even before Vladimir Putin went
into Ukraine in February of 2024
the price of gas had surged since
President Biden took office they blamed
his energy policies I know you're not
necessarily wanting to get into the
politics of that but prices were a lot
higher before that correct
well they were I'm not sure I mean go
back to October November of last year I
mean Russia came on the radar screen in
December of last year and that's when
energy Traders started pushing up prices
but if you go back to October or
November oil prices were 75 bucks a
barrel gasoline was going for you know
325 300 3.50 a gallon which is just
exactly where it was pre-pandemic yeah
when the president took office gas was
two dollars and change so it was well
under three dollars but gas was way down
during the initial parts of covet it
plunged with oil plunging in like May of
2020 right yeah two bucks was when we
were in the teeth of the pandemic no one
was driving I mean remember we were shut
down and we didn't really reopen until
you know well in about until about this
time last year hard to hard to believe
feels like ages ago it really does yeah
but you know two bucks that was because
no one was driving that that's an
economy that's flat on its back are we
in a recession now let me I
I want you to hear this exchange just on
uh on Monday Martha McCallum on Fox News
had an exchange with Gene Sperling who
is a White House economic advisor and
it's about a recession because we may
get the report on Thursday that we're in
for a second straight quarterly decline
in GDP I want you to hear this in react
I covered the economy for for many years
I was told by everybody I spoke to that
that two negative quarters two
Contracting quarters means that the
economy is in a recession that is not
the actual definition of a recession it
is a significant contractionary period
over a few months you're going to still
argue that we're not in a recession even
if we get another quarter of negative
growth I don't think there's any view
that would that would interpret the this
second quarter or these six months as
being recessionary okay
who's right well we're not in recession
I mean we're getting a boatload of jobs
I mean in the first half of this year
average monthly job growth was close to
a half a million I mean that's way
higher than what you would typically see
in a well-functioning economy it'd be
closer to 100K we had a record number of
open job positions a layoffs they were
at record loads uh so it just doesn't
make sense that you would call this
period a recession and I don't think the
Arbiters of this the you know business
cycle dating committee the group of
academic comments of the National Bureau
of economic research will label this
recession but obviously we've all heard
about that two negative quarters in a
row as a recession so
that's not true always
yeah well that's a rule of thumb you
know that historically two consecutive
quarters of negative GDP kind of lined
up very closely to the decision by the
National Bureau of economic research it
lined up but not always in this case
certainly uh not the case we did have a
rise in first-time unemployment claims
last week and that's where we would
start to see it right you know you would
expect UI claims to rise and at 250 000
per week that's where we are right now
that's okay that's consistent with a
pretty good labor market but as you
point out the trajectory the trend line
here is a little disturbing if it
continues to rise in a few weeks from
now when you ask me back we're at 275
per week or 300 per week that would
indicate that you know recession is
increasingly likely right now obviously
everybody paying more for gas paying
more for groceries there's a lot of
concern consumer spending is a big
driver for the economy
where are we on that consumers are
hanging tough they keep spending I mean
they're switching what they're spending
their money on you know in the pandemic
because we were stuck at home we're
buying lots of stuff goods and now we're
out and about and traveling and doing
other things so we're spending Less on
stuff so if you see Walmart announcing
weak sales that's because people are
switching what they're spending their
money on but they're spending their
money on I'm out traveling today and I
can tell you you know hotels are full
the airports are full people are out and
about uh and in aggregate spending is
still reasonably okay it's still good at
least good enough to keep the economy
moving forward okay now the FED may do
another three quarters of a percentage
Point interest rate uh hike we had that
in June half a percent in May quarter
percent in March this means though on
the other side for consumers to borrow
the cost is going up so what does that
do
yeah well that's part of the fed's
intent to slow the economy you know
they're raising interest rates so you
know that raises the cost of getting a
mortgage to buy home that's why the
housing market is weakening home sales
are coming down very rapidly house
prices are going flat you know it makes
it more expensive to go out and buy a
car to get it all you have to get an
auto loan and you know that'll be more
expensive the the cost of holding debt
on your credit card that's getting a lot
more expensive and sapping people's
purchasing power right so none of this
is good none of this sounds good the
fed's raising rates while I'm paying a
lot at the grocery store and I'm paying
a lot at the gas pump even though the
price of gas may be down like almost 75
cents since the record high in June it's
still historically very high yeah it's
not good though the economy is is really
in a tough spot I mean look look we're
struggling but you know hopefully with a
declining gasoline prices with the
slowing in growth uh that inflationary
pressures start to come in and if they
do then I think this economy has enough
strength that it can and made it just
way through but having said all of that
you know obviously the risks are high
and nothing else can go wrong and
goodness knows there's a lot that could
go wrong what would be the worst thing
that could happen you said a lot could
go wrong what you're you're you're
obviously a chief Economist what makes
you worried the most
the known unknowns uh you know around
oil prices so the European Union has
sanctioned Russian oil very
understandable but they haven't
implemented it yet if they Implement
those sanctions and that Russian oil
actually comes off the market the gas
oil gasoline prices are going Skyward
again that worries me and then there's
the unknown unknowns I mean you know
it's had this nightmare what if the Cat
5 hurricane blows through the gulf hits
the Texas coast wipes out a Refinery and
gas that because there's no refining
capacity you see gasoline prices go back
over five dollars a gallon that would be
enough as well so you know it's really
the key the most there's a lot of things
to be nervous about the thing I worry
most about is is those Energy prices
those oil prices gasoline prices nothing
is more pernicious to people's
pocketbooks and their Collective psyche
than having to you know go to the gas
station and pay five dollars a gallon
that's just you know too much to bear
and it's not just us I mean diesel hit a
record high that affects companies that
affect shipping it affects a lot of
things they can't always eat that cost
they have to raise prices too exactly
that you know there's people don't
recognize how important diesel is you
know that goes to those food prices you
know it goes to all the shipping costs
you know whenever you get a package from
Amazon or UPS or FedEx you know their
costs are higher and of course jet fuel
prices are higher as well and that
raises the cost of shipping goods and
obviously if you're traveling this
summer you felt it in your ticket price
so yeah the effects of these higher
energy prices you know are felt all
throughout the economy in the end do you
think through this whole period I know
you don't think we're in a recession now
do you think we will at some point hit
one because of what's happened
it's going to be close Dave you know I
worry about it I mean I think the
economy has enough resilience to manage
its way through but it needs a little
bit of luck on the pandemic and the
Russian invasion and we need some really
good Deft policy making by the FED they
got to thread the needle they got to
raise rates high enough fast enough to
slow growth keep inflation expectations
down but not so high so far that it
undermines things like housing and
pushes in a recession that's the
definition of tricky it's going to be
tricky Mark zandi Chief Economist
Moody's Analytics always good to talk to
you thanks so much thanks Dave take care
now
foreign
this is Stephen Moore with your Fox News
commentary coming up this week Senators
held a hearing on opioids and synthetic
opioids especially fentanyl as it pours
into the country at an alarming rate
Fox's film illusion has been reporting
from the border for months and not just
on the number of people crossing in so
in two separate incidents back to back
more than 50 000 fentanyl pills found at
the Nogales Arizona Port of Entry that
was just a couple of weeks ago around
the time when the DEA in Los Angeles
announced they had seized roughly 1
million fake pills containing fentanyl
in Inglewood saying in a statement that
in the first four months of this year
fentanyl related seizures were up 64
percent last year over 3 million
fentanyl pills were seized which they
said was nearly a three-fold increase
over 2020 and that's just the Los
Angeles area in the hearing Louisiana
Republican senator Bill Cassidy said
last year saw the largest increase in
opioid deaths in 50 years more than 100
000 people died we've got to control
that border if there's a message I wish
the administration to get use your tools
to control but Connecticut Democratic
senator Chris Murphy questioned the
Border argument a lot of our colleagues
think that by putting up this wall on
the border you're going to stop fentanyl
from coming into the country the reality
to spend those coming through the ports
and so we can make investments but the
idea that it's the the UN the unwalled
portions of the Border where the
fentanyl is pouring in is just not what
the facts bear out and when it comes to
the ports Senator Cassidy noted that
cartels ship in fentanyl made with
Chinese ingredients and chemicals
through the mail and declare the
packages are worth less than eight
hundred dollars to avoid CBP inspections
fentanyl obviously is a very powerful
synthetic opioid it's made in Labs it's
not plant-based it's very addictive it's
very cheap the cartels are taking total
advantage of the addicted population and
the market in America and the poisoning
our country Derek maltz is a former DEA
special agent I don't even look at
fentanyl anymore as a drug because it's
actually killing it historically levels
like we've never seen this in the
history of the country and that's part
of the problem now the lawmakers and
some of the government officials they're
still talking with the old Antiquated
talking points on the opioid crisis when
kids were like taking legitimate
prescription pills oxycodone and
different types of opioids that they
were getting from the doctors and from
the pill bottles and they were all real
drugs these are fake drugs this is not
these are fake prescriptions they're not
real opioids they're it's fentanyl made
in labs and it's killing because they
don't have like chemists that are mixing
up the chemicals and making sure there's
a small amount and it only takes two
milligrams to kill so it's a it's a game
changer in the crisis in America but
people aren't necessarily buying
fentanyl right like you said they're
buying a pill that they think is maybe
like an oxycodone or a hydrocodone and
it's actually a counterfeit and it's
laced with fentanyl is that what's is
that sort of what's Happening
yes we'll see like what's happening is
like the younger generation you're
hearing about a lot of 13 year olds 14
year olds 15 year olds that are dying
from these fake pills they're going out
trying to buy legitimate type
prescription drugs like Xanax or you
know oxycodone or Adderall or Percocet
because they for some reason they either
have anxiety or they have other some
type of you know issue going on that
they think these drugs are going to help
them they definitely have no idea that
the pills that they're buying are fake
they're coming from these filthy labs in
Mexico and they're going to kill them so
there's a whole new type of user Because
the Internet and the social media sites
is giving people access that they never
had before because they're able to sell
this stuff and the younger generation is
buying it there's also a population of
people that are very severely addicted
that know this fentanyl on the streets
they want to buy fentanyl because
fentanyl is going to give them the best
high and they really don't pay attention
to whether or not it's going to kill
them or not they just need their high
and then there's a lot of casual drug
users that may go out on a Friday night
to use cocaine if they snort a couple
lines of cocaine but they have no idea
that the Mexican cartels are putting
fentanyl in this cocaine so they're
dying and have no idea it has fentanyl
another issue that that came up and you
just sort of referenced it there in the
in the Senate hearing is where all this
is coming from right physically it's
coming from Mexico but you and I've
talked about this before a lot of the
ingredients are coming from China we
know the Chinese government has rules
against manufacturing and producing
fentanyl still it somehow gets to Mexico
Senator Cassidy was among those who was
like this is the Chinese communist
government if they want to stop the
shipment of fentanyl ingredients they
just would do they do they just not want
to
well look there's a lot of people
including myself that believe this is
another tool in the Communist Party of
China's toolbox to destabilize and
Destroy America so it's part of their
unrestricted Warfare right now I
personally believe based on all my years
of experience and understanding of this
issue they are using the Mexican cartels
as the proxy to destroy America just
like Hezbollah is used by Iran as a
proxy to do the dirty work for for Iran
and it's the same concept at first they
they were actually sending Mass amounts
of fentanyl directly to America in the
mail services through the internet or
the dark web but now they started
pushing the product directly to to
Mexico and even now they're pushing like
multi-ton quantities of precursor
chemicals into the cartels lab so
they're making it in Mexico now so it's
it's an evolution now one thing that a
lot of people don't realize and I was
fortunate enough to be the head of the
Special Operations Division to follow
this Evolution they started bombing
America back in like 2008 2009 with
synthetic cannabinoids and synthetic
capitals like K2 spice bath salts yeah
and nobody in America knew what that
stuff was it was all coming from Wuhan
style labs and that was going on for
several years and it hit us by surprise
like I was the head of the operation I
never heard of you know synthetic
marijuana K2 spice they're selling it in
these little bags attracting kids you
know Scooby snacks and King Kong and all
these colorful labels and what was
happening is these kids were smoking
this stuff and they were getting
seriously sick respiratory illnesses
they were dying in some cases emergency
room emissions were going up this
started in you know like I said around
2009 or so and then in about 2012 we
started seeing fentanyl coming from
these same labs so they changed from
pretty much these synthetic cannabinoids
cathenons to fentanyl then we started
seeing all these deaths in America as a
matter of fact in 2014 when I was still
in charge of this operation we started
something called operation deadly
Merchant because for the first time we
started seeing Mass amounts of debt in
America with fentanyl on the streets
laced in heroin at the time okay
primarily heroin and we had no idea what
was going on what was all coming from
these labs and then this was going on
every year was picking up momentum we
saw more and more Mexican cartel
involvement we saw Dominican
distribution networks involved as well
but then when President Trump started
putting pressure on China to classify
their analogs and to control their
analogs say exports then we started
seeing another shift now the Chinese
were sending pure fentanyl right to
Mexico which was then being mixed in all
types of drugs and and what was
happening is we started seeing more and
more deaths so the deaths were
escalating because it was pure Fentanyl
and now what we're seeing is the cartels
are making this stuff in the labs and
they're now capitalizing on the pill
Market because Americans are so addicted
to prescription pills the cartels are
now making a business decision with that
creative and deceptive marketing plan to
get as many people hooked on this drug
to make maximize profits but
unfortunately it's killing Americans at
record levels
wow um that's terrifying Derek um yes
talk to me about the Border because we
we see these large busts happening there
was a huge one a couple weeks ago in Los
Angeles I know you know about it yeah um
those men driving through Tulare County
back in June they didn't show up for
their court hearing last week they had
thousands of fentanyl pills but we also
hear about these you know half a million
gotaways uh people sneaking across the
border just this fiscal year alone uh
and and members of Congress were just at
the border this week Republicans begging
for something to be done about the
Border but then in the Senate hearing
you had others say well a lot of these
drugs these drug busts are happening at
ports where are we in your mind on the
border what should be done at the border
regarding fentanyl regarding drugs that
isn't being done
well for one I was down in Arizona I was
down in Texas in the Rio Grande Valley I
got briefed up by the top experts in
border security former Homeland Security
officials these guys are my friends
listen to The Border Patrol listen to
the DPS in Texas the bottom line is they
have to finish the wall and they have to
force all traffic into America through
the ports of Entry that's number one
then we can put all the best resources
and the latest and greatest technology
screening equipment right there at the
Port of Entry so we can maximize the
interdictions of drugs and we can
properly investigate all the immigrants
that are coming in through the port of
entrance if you have these openings in
the wall the cartels are taken total
Advantage they're flooding The Zone with
the border patrol they're sending their
drugs their high value targets they're
bringing their money into guns
southbound because it's a wide open
border and there's plenty of drugs that
are coming through in between the port
of entries I do you agree that the
majority of the drugs in the tractor
trailers are coming through the port of
entries right but you got to understand
the problem is that the border patrol is
inundated with migrant processing and
bureaucratic paperwork babysitting they
can't do border security and they're
doing a great job considering they don't
have resources that's why you just saw
another recent five thousand pounds of
methamphetamine that they've seized in
California back in November they see 17
500 pounds of meth 400 pounds of
fentanyl they're seizing a lot of drugs
despite the fact that they have such
limited uh resources and the morale is
down really low right now because
they're not properly supported they
can't do the job that they were signed
up for so it's a total negligence on on
behalf of the Department of Homeland
Security the White House and everyone
else responsible for security of our
country and the Ghana ways to be honest
with you is the most scary part of it
from my standpoint because we
investigated in Project Cassandra
hezbollah's role with the Mexican drug
cartels we exposed that while I was at
the Special Operations Division and we
watched the intricate relationships
building between Hezbollah one of the
world's most serious you know terrorist
organizations they are all over that
region so we have no idea all these
known godaways that they're reporting
for 55 000 a month we don't even know
who these people are where they came
from what the motive is why are they
here what are they going to do they can
be plotting stuff every day of the week
right here in our backyards and we
wouldn't even know who they are or where
they are that's scary of course you have
to get more resources for law
enforcement you have to get more
technology for law enforcement and CBP
and you have to buy the latest and
greatest stuff because we're at war with
these countries that's the bottom line
it legitimately is you could say what
you want people think this is a drug
crisis this is a mass poisoning on our
future generation and if we keep losing
hundreds of thousands a year who's going
to be in the military who's going to be
the pilots and the doctors and the
lawyers and the bus drivers and the
teachers they're not going to be around
because we're losing too many kids so
it's really sad and it's very very
negligent on behalf of the government
that they're not stepping up and they're
not doing the job to protect the
Citizens First of America
Derek maltz thank you so much for your
time and your expertise we really
appreciate it thank you and have a great
day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is your kid getting ready to go to
kindergarten a new study published in
the journal Pediatrics has some ideas to
make sure your kids get off to the right
start and it's not just a backpack a
lunchbox or crayons but it's at least 10
hours of sleep researchers monitor sleep
duration of kindergarteners over four
week long periods and had the kids
teachers evaluate their transition into
formal schooling it found that the more
consistently children got 10 hours of
sleep during the night the better the
children's peer relationships
relationships with teachers overall
academic performance and site
recognition of words the American
Academy of sleep medicine already
suggests that kindergarten age kids get
10 to 13 hours of sleep but that is over
the course of the day and includes the
sleeping at night and naps during the
afternoon but the journal pediatric
study says that 10 hours of sleep at
night makes all the difference
researchers say if you have a little one
getting ready to go to kindergarten now
may be the time to start those good
sleep habits they suggest a 9 pm bedtime
or earlier eliminating screens at least
30 minutes before bedtime and developing
a bedtime routine like taking a bath
reading a book and creating a calming
environment the study suggested
establishing healthy nighttime sleep
habits before the start of the school
was especially helpful for the Fox News
rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from Fox News for Amazon
Alexa just say Alexa play news from fox
in Fox News it's the latest when you
need it on demand from Fox News and
Amazon Alexa subscribe to this podcast
at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Stephen Moore
what's on your mind Liberals are very
good at chasing rich people out of their
states blue States lose billions of tax
dollars and many tens of thousands of
jobs as a result of the migration of
rich people leaving High tax and high
crime States consider Elon Musk he left
California for Texas he paid 11 billion
dollars in federal and state taxes last
year and the state of California will
likely lose billions in tax revenues now
that he's gone and that doesn't include
all the property and sales taxes that he
and his Tesla employees will now pay in
Texas rather than in the Golden State
Texas by the way has no income tax then
there is the famous story of investor
Paul Tudor Jones when he left
Connecticut a few years ago and took his
business and earnings to Florida he
single-handedly drilled a 40 million
dollar Revenue hole in the state budget
in Hartford billionaire Citadel Capital
founder Ken Griffin one of the most
philanthropic residents in the history
of Illinois has moved to where else
Florida Bloomberg wrote a superb
well-researched story on what Griffin
who's 53 years old has meant to the life
and civil culture of Chicago
Griffin has donated more than 600
million dollars to organizations in the
windy city since coming to Chicago the
Museum of Science and Industry plans to
take on his name in 2024 thanks to his
massive contributions to science he has
been a major donor to schools churches
meal programs Northwestern Medicine The
Field Museum and the Chicago Symphony
many of these organizations told
Bloomberg that they worry whether they
can replace such a generous benefactor
good question the moral of these stories
is that class Warfare liberals can't
seem to help themselves they always kill
the geese that laid the golden eggs
pretty soon Blue State America won't
have any more Rich geese to pluck
I'm Stephen Moore a senior fellow at
Freedom works and the author of the new
book Godzilla how the Relentless growth
of government is devouring our economy
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network I'm
Ben Dominic Fox News contributor and
editor of thetransom.com daily
newsletter and I'm inviting you to join
a conversation every week it's the Ben
Dominic podcast subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes